bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors l'escaladé
des affrontements entre israël et les
palestiniens est ce que cela peut
basculer vers une guerre ouverte comme
on l'a vu en 2014 ça n'est pas exclue
vous avez entendu de part et d'autre une
volonté de d'en découdre un des miens
mille netanyahu a clairement dit que les
bombardements n'allait pas s'arrêter
qu'il pour cela il devait y avoir au
préalable une période calme et côté
palestinien ismaïl haniyeh dans
affirmant qu'il était prêt à un cessez
le feu est bien dit également sa
détermination
donc voilà le niveau n'est pas encore je
crois dans une désescalade
les médiations internationales donné par
l'egypte le qatar les nations unies pour
l'instant n'ont pas porté leurs fruits
parce que parce que j'en pense qu'il
peut encore engranger sur ces c'est cet
accès de violence
israël dynamité miiaou est dans une
position difficile de le montrer à sa
population alors qu'il est toujours en
phase de formation d'un gouvernement et
que bien il répond fermement et côté
hamas côté palestinien gaza et bien on
ne veut pas donner l'impression
finalement de céder donc pour l'instant
je pense que c'est encore un petit peu
irréaliste de penser qu'il peut y avoir
une des rescapées
cela étant il n'ira pages on se taquine
une guerre totale parce que à moyen
terme
personne n'ya intérêt mais ce genre de
bombardements ses ripostes avec le fait
que le hamas mme on dispose et c'est la
grande nouveauté par rapport à alien
quinzaine d'années des missiles capables
d'atteindre aviv et de susciter une
panique et bien le hamas dispose d'un
arsenal qui lui permet justement en deux
de te lire tête pendant un certain jour
avec israël
alors vous avez évoqué la situation
politique difficile dans laquelle se
trouve le premier ministre benyamin
nétanyahou qui est affaibli le hamas
aussi de son côté il ya des élections
qui sont qui se profile côté palestinien
qui ont été reportés à une date initiale
était prévue initialement le 22 mai est
ce que les deux camps ont finalement ont
un intérêt politique à ce que la
situation s'envenime de limay mais comme
je vous le disais à un intérêt politique
est ce que ce qu'ils montrent leur île
bande leurs muscles le hamas
effectivement et privés de ces élections
à rome la décision prise par mahmoud
abbas de les reporter est donc
aujourd'hui le hamas se sent en position
de force on se résout à part justement à
la pointe de la de la résistance
palestinienne à l'occupation israélienne
et et cotiseraient dire c'est un petit
peu la même chose on est dans une dans
une dans un processus de désignation du
gouvernement et le public à pans de son
gouvernement une politique une même
faire il ya aussi un autre élément qui
ne plaide pas en faveur d'une
désescalade à court terme c'est que vous
l'avez vu ces dernières heures ces
dernières 24 heures un certain nombre de
villes arabes israéliennes c'est-à-dire
peuplée de deux palestiniens qui sont
restés à l'intérieur du territoire
israélien en 1948 lorsque israël a été
créé eh bien ces villes se sont embrasés
on pense notamment à l'aide de
l'aéroport à talal ben gourion qui a
d'ailleurs été fermé et est donc là
c'est aussi c'est un je dirais c'est un
ami les fronts qui pourrait s'ouvrir ça
n'est pas de bon de bonne augure pour
israël parce que ça montre que
effectivement la population arabe
israélienne et solidaires des
palestiniens de gaza et de la haie de la
cisjordanie et donc on va surveiller
aussi de très près comment vont évoluer
les réactions des arabes israéliens si
les tensions si les émeutes ont eu lieu
ces dernières sera le club pourrait se
propager à d'autres villes ce qui est
frappant c'est
l'impuissance en tout cas c'est
l'impression que l'on a de la communauté
internationale le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu va tenir aujourd'hui une nouvelle
réunion d'urgence et la deuxième en
trois jours
à quoi faut-il s'attendre en sachant que
les états unis opposent systématiquement
leur veto à toute condamnation d'israël
oui vous l'avez dit je pense que les
états unis même si la relation que joe
biden et benyamin nétanyahou n'est pas
bonne son talent le premier allié
d'israël
donc les états unis vont témoigner de
leur solidarité ils l'ont déjà fait donc
il n'ya pas grand chose un temps dans
l'immédiat cela étant on connaît la
l'issue la médiation interviendra
probablement par l'egypte qui a noué des
relations des relations anciennes avec
les palestiniens et en particulier avec
le hamas à gaza
le qatar en coulisses et très influent
parce que c'est le qatar qui finance une
grande partie des besoins de la bande de
gaza et donc voilà simplement on n'est
pas encore dans cette phase de
désescalade
et il faut que israël forte de sa
supériorité militaire de l'impression
c'est une fausse impression parce que
parce que l'accalmie à laquelle on
assistera dans quelques jours dans une
semaine et bien duras durera quelques
temps mais si comme rien aucune solution
d'aidé trouvé ou qu'une solution de
forme n'est trouvée concernant le
processus de paix où le conflit
israélo-palestinien et bien vous on aura
pendant quelques
dans quelques mois dans quelques années
de nouveaux obscène accès de violence
comme on en a régulièrement depuis 2000
2005 israël s'est retiré de la bande de
gaza et la communauté internationale et
mon rôle à bedie est impuissante parce
que elle accrue ces dernières années
justement que le conflit
israélo-palestinien bien c'était
assoupie qu'il y avait plus de de réels
dangers l'administration preuve vous et
les thèses d'israël les palestiniens
sont divisés
mahmoud abbas à la tête de l'autorité
palestinienne est carbonisé mais il y a
le hamas à gaza qui est toujours là et
et la nature a horreur du vide
gdba 0 à jérusalem il ya vingt ans les
roquettes les premières roquettes du
hamas avec une portée de 1 2 3 km la
plupart d'entre elles d'ailleurs n'at il
n'aime pas à dépasser la bande de gaza
aujourd'hui et bien les roquettes
atteignent tel-aviv c'est à dire 90 km
plus loin et donc que le hamas a créé
une espèce de capacité d'une mini
capacité de dissuasion et entretient un
climat un climat de peur de panique qui
le rend un adversaire beaucoup plus
dangereux qu'il était il n'ya ni à 20
ans et donc on en revient toujours la
même question faute d'avancées dans le
processus de paix même si le monde arabe
sera proche d'israël
d'autres pays on pense aux nantis qui à
l'iran voire même la turquie eux donc
des acteurs non-arabes occupe le vide et
et est donc aide c'est le cas de l'iran
le hamas à se doter d'équipements
militaires qui sont beaucoup plus
performants que celle dont ils
disposaient il ya une vingtaine d'années
alors pour sortir justement de ce
conflit ouvert
on sait que le point de départ des
tensions actuelles c'est l'expulsion
potentiel de famille palestinien
habitant proche de l'esplanade des
mosquées
mais c'est vrai qu'au si le blocus de
gaza depuis 2007
un problème récurrent aussi qui est posé
sur la scène internationale est-ce que
ça ça peut être une clé la levée de ce
blocus justement à la fin des tensions
israélo-palestiniennes
ça me paraît difficilement envisageable
à court terme que le blocus de gaza soit
levé
parce que pour qu'il soulevait ils ont
un accord beaucoup plus je dirais
globale y compris régionale
entre israël et est non seulement ses
nouveaux alliés arabes que sont les
émirats arabes unis même s'ils sont peu
intervenant dans la bande de gaza mais
aussi le qatar la turquie qui sont des
sponsors politique du hamas d également
l'iran et pour un cet accord on est très
très loin puisque israël et l'iran sont
à couteaux tirés notamment sur la
question du nucléaire iranien
donc non je crois qu'il faut hélas il
faut être avoir des objectifs des
ambitions modestes il faut il faut faire
en sorte que le calme revienne par une
médiation égyptienne qatarienne
américaine en coulisses
concernant israël russes aussi on a vu
de la lumière utile comme il a de bonnes
relations de tania hook et bien à a son
mot à dire
mais voilà il faut être très modeste
d'abord la priorité c'est de ramener le
calme pour éviter les les les
bombardements du hamas sur israël qui
sont inacceptables mais pour éviter
aussi les bombardements d'israël sur la
bande de gaza et
et puis aussi réglé fixation de la
violence à jérusalem avec cette affaire
des expulsions de familles
palestiniennes cherchera alors justement
une dernière question georges malbrunot
sur le sort des palestiniens à ce que ça
peut devenir une préoccupation majeure
sur la scène internationale et la scène
médiatique parce qu'on sait que il ya ce
rapport de human watch tout récemment
qui a qualifié d' apartheid la politique
d'israël à l'égard des arabes sur son
sol et des palestiniens dans les
territoires occupés et puis à ce tweet
aujourd'hui de la procureur de la cour
pénale internationale qui s'est dite
inquiète de l'escaladé des violences
entre israéliens et palestiniens
notant la commission de possibles crimes
de guerre alors je ne fais pas mais en
tout cas ce qui ce qui est évident c'est
que contrairement à ce qu'on croyait
être et croyez moi ce que voulaient
croire beaucoup de diplomates
beaucoup de médias le conflit israélo
palestinien n'est pas réglé il est
pareil l'aider tout et on en a
aujourd'hui la preuve est donc
encore une fois tant que ce conflit ne
sera pas réglée et bien il y aura de
manière récurrente des accès de
violences meurtrières entre israéliens
et palestiniens dont je dirais que c'est
une piqûre de rappel qui pour tout le
monde pour nous rappeler que finalement
même si sa demande de pays arabes sur la
proche d'israël même s'il ya eu
désaccord d'abraham dernier est bien le
conflit israélo-palestinien encore une
fois même s'il n'est plus la matrice de
tous les conflits au moyen-orient comme
on le pensait dans les années 80-90 ça
reste ça reste un jeu direct
un abcès purulent est temps que cet
abcès n'est pas réglé donc une solution
des parts apportées à ce conflit et ben
il y aura de la violence de parts et
l'eau merci beaucoup à vous georges
malbrunot je rappelle que vous êtes
grand reporter au figaro spécialiste du
moyen orient